I have some delightfully cringe-worthy
video for you today I almost fell off my
chair I cringed so hard when I saw this
Fox News did a segment this was part of
Fox and Friends apparently they brought
on a conservative squad and by that they
mean a right-wing response to the squad
of actual members of Congress all of
whom were members of the Democratic
Party and of diverse backgrounds Fox
News's conservative squad is not of
diverse backgrounds it's four
congressional candidates who are running
to fight socialism among other things in
the United States they want to be the
anti squad effectively now you'll hear
the host name the candidates so I won't
this is maybe the dumbest thing I've
heard on a few levels which were going
to discuss shortly at first I was
convinced this was a Saturday Night Live
parody but it's not the women are all
obviously white presumably so-called
Christians and it is actually difficult
to watch because this doesn't appear to
be a parody they actually seem to be
serious here let's take a look
public in Alabama congressional
candidate Jessica Taylor joins us now
with the conservative squad we have
Minnesota congressional candidate
Michelle Fishbach South Carolina
congressional candidate Nancy mace and
Texas congressional candidate Beth Van
Dyne thank you ladies for being with us
Jessica congratulations you actually did
this yes ma'am
when you ordered these ladies that want
to form a conservative squad with you
what goes through your mind you know I'm
just honored that they want to join in
this fight and that's exactly what it is
you know we are losing the younger
generations of this country and I'm so
grateful that they're willing to join up
and help in this cause okay Michelle why
did you want to be a part of the squad
you know this is about bringing the
conservative message to the people of
the United States
so that people understand that we're
looking at do-nothing Democrats they're
obsessing about impeachment and not
really doing anything for the people of
the United States anymore you know you
take a look at western Minnesota the
district that I live in and they're
they're ignoring us MCA they've finally
gotten around to it a year later but the
farmers out in western Minnesota need us
MCA and they waited and waited but they
have plenty of time for impeachment and
the Sham that that is and they just
continue to to obsess about that and not
do the things that the people of the
United States
really need these are the types of
talking points that only work in the
media equivalent of like a medical
cleanroom or maybe better said a media
safe space we are losing the younger
generation
well yeah Republican policy has
destroyed the earnings potential and
savings potential of the younger
centered generation college costs have
exploded the students and the younger
people are riddled with student debt
wages are stagnant and they don't have
health care so yeah you're gonna lose
young people as a result of that the
do-nothing Dems they say well Democrats
don't control the Senate and between
Mitch McConnell and Donald Trump's veto
power at the White House they can do
very very little farmers are struggling
and we really need us MC a well the
farmers are struggling because of Donald
Trump's trade policy they don't mention
that of course every single one of these
dumb talking points would be dismantled
instantly and anything but a safe space
and they are being held up these four
women as some kind of moral right wing
Crusaders and it gets even worse let's
continue the video Nancy why is the
squat important to you well you know if
you look at my life I got my start as a
waitress at Waffle House I became the
first woman to graduate from the Citadel
the Military College of South Carolina
20 years ago today I'm a businesswoman
and state lawmaker running for the
United States Congress and this is about
our future this is the American dream
and you see the Democrats they've taken
a sharp left turn under the influence of
the socialist squad and you look at us
and this is socialism versus American
values of freedom and job creation and
we all understand up here today that
people flourish under freedom and 2020
next year is pivotal for our country and
you know we see so many women across the
the country right now Republican Women
who are picking up the mantle and want
to serve they say enough is enough my
kids in my country are worth fighting
for and that's what this is about
essentially Beth how about you well I
look at right now we really do have a
Congress it's run by extremists and it's
dangerous for America because they're
not doing anything we haven't seen
solutions for out of control health care
costs this is not socialism versus
anything there are almost no socialists
in the United States in prominent
positions of power at the national level
the idea that the squad or the
Democratic Party or Democrats or whoever
are pushing socialism is ridiculous this
is a false debate the country has not
gone hard left the country increasingly
realizes that the things that they have
in other capitalist countries like
Norway and Finland Denmark Canada
Australia Sweden things like health care
and education we should also have and as
a rich country we can also afford to
have that's not socialism that's not far
left this reminds me of Trump's last
State of the Union address you might
remember it from yelled out at the last
State of the Union I think it was the
last one maybe the previous but I'm
pretty sure it was the last he yelled
out too much Republican applause in the
crowd we will never be a socialist
nation there's no risk of that right now
but to say ever nobody knows what could
happen in a long time but who is trying
to make this a socialist country I get
it there are some socialists okay but
actual socialists in positions of power
are few and far between they're not
making policy they are you know when you
talk about tuition free college paid out
of taxes where people who get really
rich from their businesses pay more
that's a capitalist thing that happens
in socialism you wouldn't have those
ultra rich people except when the
socialist state is a corrupt state in
which case you wouldn't that happens but
then they probably wouldn't be paying
high taxes single-payer healthcare is a
capitalist idea where the fruits of
capitalism are used to make sure
everyone has health care regardless of
whether they can personally afford it
based on the job that they have they are
setting up this fake enemy of socialism
when they are really fighting more
progressive capitalists that's really
the majority of what the the ideas are
that they claim to be fighting as far
left it's total cringe but the really
scary thing about this the thing that is
depressing is that in a lot of parts of
the country this stuff probably is
appealing I understand that as someone
who lives in Massachusetts I laugh when
I see stuff like this but because it
seems almost like a parody but there are
parts of the
country where folks like these could
actually win and we need to be
activating and organizing against them
because otherwise they will win and even
if it's a fake war against socialism
that they think they're waging they can
still be successful as long as they
prevent serious progressive reforms from
actually taking place so I know that we
laugh it off in a lot of parts of the
country and we joke in this is a Fox
News echo chamber these folks are never
going to get elected nobody's going to
fall for the false the the straw men
that they are putting together that's
not true in a lot of parts of the
country this stuff resonates and sadly I
mean even here in Massachusetts in some
of the more rural parts you see a
sympathy for this type of ideology so
we've got to fight every district we've
got to fight every race we've got to
fight all the way to and through the
November of 2020 election if we want a
shot at this because this that they are
tricking people they are convincing
people and as scary as it is as
laughable as it is also in many ways
we've got to fight it at every
opportunity